hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to doki doki literature
club okay
alright everybody hold on to your horses
cuz I got the poem of your dreams right
here alright who do I show to first hey
I better save on this one this is genius
poem can't let this genius go hi Monica
hey come on I should start with Monica
yesterday she seemed eager to read my
palm and I want her to know I'm putting
in or I'm putting in effort oh yeah
putting in effort Monica hi barb
hi Monica having a good time so far
sure okay ah yeah good glad to hear it
by the way since you're new and
everything if you ever have any
suggestions for the club like new
activities or things we can do better
I'm always listening and then I'll
ignore you and punch you in the face for
daring to change my beautiful Club
don't be afraid to bring things up okay
all right I'll keep that in mind of
course I'll be afraid to bring things up
I'm much better off just going with the
flow until I'm more settled in anyway
want to share the poem with me it's kind
of embarrassing but I guess I have to
don't worry more we're all a little
embarrassed today you know you know I
don't trust you
well that's okay but it's the sort of
Barry that we'll all learn to get past
soon yeah that's true
a hand Monica my poem mmm-hmm great job
more I was going oh in my head while
reading it not out loud though I would
never do that
it's really metaphorical I'm not sure
why but I didn't expect to you to go for
something so deep I guess I
underestimated you
hey sure was it the vivacious it was
probably the vivacious it's easiest for
me to keep everyone's expectations low
that way it always counts when I put in
some effort ah that's not very fair well
I guess it worked out anyway you know
that Yuri likes his kind of writing
write writing this full of imagery and
symbolism unlike say Orry who likes
simple and direct words to describe
happiness and sadness
Yuri likes it when readers are left to
derive their own meaning out of it it's
very challenging to write like that
effectively both allowing people to get
something out of it just by feel or
letting them deeply analyze all the
nuances it can take years of practice
which I'm assuming Yuri has at this
point
I never really asked though I'm sure I'm
nowhere near her level yet don't worry
so much about that you do your own thing
just keep exploring and learn by trying
new things I'm sure I'll end up trying
different things a lot it could take a
while before I'm feel comfortable doing
this that's okay
I'd love to see you try new things
that's the best way to find the kind of
style that suits you everyone else might
be a little bit biased towards their own
kinds of styles but I'll always help you
find what suits you the most so don't
force yourself to write the way everyone
else wants you to write it's not like
you have to worry about impressing them
or anything
ha ha ha ha ha okay I like this anyway
you do you want to read my poem now
don't worry I'm not very good you sound
pretty confident for someone who claims
to not be very good that's because I
have to sound confident that doesn't
mean I always feel that way you know I
see well let's read it then ah hole in
the wall it could what kind of hole we
talking about it could have been me see
the direction the spackle protrudes a
noisy neighbor an angry boyfriend I'll
never know I wasn't home I peer inside
for a clue no I can't see I real blind
like a film left out in the Sun but it's
too late my retinas already scorched
with a permanent copy of the meaningless
image it's just a little hole it wasn't
too bright it was too deep stretching
forever into everything a whole of
infinite choices I realize now that I
wasn't looking in I was looking out and
he on the other side was looking in
buuuut so what do you think oh I've
never been so excited about a hole in my
life oh it's a beautiful thing hmm
it's very freeform if that's what you
call it sorry I'm not really the right
person ask for feedback uh-huh it's okay
yeah that kind of style has gotten
pretty popular nowadays that is a lot of
poems have been putting emphasis on the
timing between words and lines when
performed out loud it can be really
powerful what was the inspiration
between behind this one
ah well I'm not sure if I know how to
put it I guess you could say that I had
some kind of epiphany recently it's been
influencing my poems a bit an epiphany
yeah something like that
I'm kind of nervous to talk about deep
stuff like that because it's coming kind
of coming on strongly maybe after
everyone is better friends with each
other anyway here's Monica's writing tip
of the day sometimes when you're writing
a poem or a story your brain gets too
fixated on a specific point if you try
so hard to make it perfect then you'll
never make any progress just force
yourself to get something down on paper
and tidy the up later and another way to
think about it is this if you keep your
pen in the same spot for too long you'll
just get a big dark puddle of ink so
just move your hand and go with the flow
that's my advice for the day thanks for
listening all right cool
all right who should I show my poem to
next about no one Oh
Natsuki sorry now Sookie I haven't
talked to you yet Hey well it's about
what I expected from someone like you
it's a little blunt well excuse me it's
not like I said that was bad
it just didn't evoke any emotions so
basically it's not cute enough for your
tastes do you want to get smacked
they'll pass huh well anyway I guess I
need to show you mine not that you'll
like it
Eagles can fly monkeys can climb
crickets can leap horses can race owls
can seek cheetahs can run Eagles can fly
people can try but that's about it
ah that's beautiful bit of all I like it
I really like it actually I like it I
told you that you weren't gonna like it
I liked it
what just be honest I am why are you so
convinced that I wouldn't like it
oh oh because everyone in high school
thinks that writing has to be all
sophisticated and stuff so people don't
even take my writing seriously huh but
isn't the point of poems for people to
express themselves your writing style
wouldn't make your message any less
valid yeah exactly I like it when it's
easy to read but it hits you hard like
in this poem seeing everyone around you
do great things can be really
disheartening so I decided to write
about it yeah I understand but the other
nice thing about simple writing is that
it puts more weight on the wordplay like
I set up for a rhyme at the end but then
it made [ __ ] made it fall flat on his
purpose it helps to bring out the
feeling in the last line so you did it I
guess more went into it than I realized
that's what I meant that's what it means
to be a pro and glad you learned
something didn't expect that from the
youngest one here did you yeah I guess
not
I decided to humor her with the last
comment I don't really care how old
everyone is but if nan Sookie is feeling
proud then I won't want to take that
away from her oh how about say Ari say
ari Hait say Ari so I our eight this is
a good poem or you're sure it's your
first time of course not that good am I
the kind of guy who'll be writing poems
in his spare time I guess you're right
you're pretty terrible but that's why it
impressed me well to be honest I was
afraid that you wouldn't do it seriously
but that you wouldn't write one at all
I'm really happy to say you wrote one it
reminds me of how you really are part of
the club now not to mention the fact
that I'm saying in front of you in the
club room yeah well of course I'm not
really into it yet but that doesn't mean
I'll break my promise see it's like I
said before more deep down you're not
selfish at all you know that's a
backhanded compliment trying new things
like this for other people that's
something that only really good people
do Thanks I guess I'm not sure if cor
sees the full picture of my motive here
then again I can't deny that she's part
of the reason I joined knowing how much
this means to her at all yeah and I'm
gonna make sure you have lots of funny
you're okay
oh all right that will be my way of
thanking you all right I'm gonna hold
you to that
okay now you read my poem do right don't
worry I'm really bad at this
yeah
or hang on wait I got saved again I
don't know why but I just got saved
okay we'll see about that dear sunshine
the way you glow through my blinds in
the morning it makes me feel like you
missed me kissing my forehead to help me
out of bed making me rub the sleepy from
[Laughter]
are you asking me to come out and play
are you trusting me to wish away a rainy
day I look above the sky is blue it's a
secret but I trust you too if it wasn't
for you I could sleep forever but I'm
not mad I want breakfast
cool say Yuri this is just a guess but
did you wait until this morning to write
this no just just a little bit you can't
answer just a little bit to a yes-or-no
question I forgot to do it last night
well at least that makes me feel better
about myself don't be mean I still try
my best
oh yeah I didn't mean to say that it was
a bad poem it came out nicer how should
I put it it sounds just like you really
yeah especially that last line I made
eggs and toast even though you were late
to school it's bad to skip breakfast
I get all cranky well I guess there's no
point in arguing I can't really see you
as being cranky anyway anyway thanks for
showing me you guys see Rory this was so
much fun
Monica is the best oh yeah the next time
I won't forget and I'm gonna write the
best balm ever well I guess I look
forward to it huh interesting
alright well it's his URI left sighs I'm
taking a dark turn yet but I got a funny
feeling about it
cause your reads a poem I noticed her
eyes lighten exceptional yeah what was
that what did you did I say that out
loud you're a first covers her mouth but
then ends up covering her whole face Oh
her mouth just grows exponentially just
keep that [ __ ] contained I uh he's gonna
hate me um you really didn't do anything
wrong URI yeah that's
I I guess you're right what am I getting
so nervous for you've got great thumbs
after all ha ha ha
you already takes a breath so what kind
of writing experience do you have your
use of imagery and metaphors indicate
you've written a lot of poetry before
really wow that's a huge compliment
coming from you this is actually my
first time really Oh Yuri stares at me
blankly then looks at my poem again well
I know that I just mean Oh Yuri trails
off unable to find an excuse she traces
her finger along the words in the poem
as if breaking it down more thoroughly
yeah ok this is the reason I was able to
tell it's just that there are specific
writing habits that are usually typical
of new writers and have been through
that myself I kind of learned to pick up
on them I think the most noticeable
thing I recognize in new writers is that
they try to make their style very
deliberate in other words they tend to
pick a writing style separate from the
topic matter and they form fit the two
together the end result is that both a
style and the expressiveness are
weakened
once your refines her train of thought
it's as if it Demeter totally changes
her stammering is completely gone and
she sounds like an expert of course
that's not something you can be blamed
for there are so many different skills
and techniques that go into writing even
a simple poem not just finding them and
building them but getting them gonna
work together is probably the most
challenging part it might take you some
time but it all comes with practice and
learning by example and trying new
things
I also hope that everyone else in the
club gives you valuable feedback
Natsuki can be a little biased biased
now um well never mind I shouldn't be
talking about people like that sorry
it's fine I'm not sure if you raised
apologizing to herself
to me or not Sookie do you mind if I
read your poem now please go I'd love to
share my thought process behind it Yuri
smiles dreamily as if that's a rare
opportunity for her which itself is kind
of funny after all isn't this supposed
to be a literature Club ah ghost under
the light the tendrils of my hair
illuminate beneath the amber glow
bathing it must be this one the last
remaining street lights have withstood
the test of time
the last yet to be replaced by the
sickening blue green hue of the future I
bathe calm breathing air of the present
but living in the past
the light flickers i flicker back
alright so your ghost is always saying
your ghost I gotta I said ghost girl
okay I know I get it I'm sorry I have
such terrible handwriting what I wasn't
thinking that at all but it took you a
long time to read I'm more very stupid
you need to understand this about more
MORE Varia dummy well I just don't read
script very often I actually think your
handwriting is pretty good that's a
relief
also I like the poem yeah even though
it's short it was really descriptive oh
it wasn't too short I usually write
longer poems not at all I'm really glad
you like it I'll be honest since it's
our first time sharing I wanted to write
something a little more mild something
easy to digest I suppose are you in the
ghost story
aren't you a ghost your thumb felt very
solid who actually the story isn't about
a ghost at all more really I must have
totally missed the point well I suppose
you did only glanced over it after all
but remember that poets often express
their own thoughts feelings and
experiences in their work they usually
do more than tell a simple story or
paint a picture in this case perhaps the
subject of the poem is only being
symbolically compared to a ghost
lingering in her last remaining place of
comfort unable to let go of the past and
soon to be left with nothing that's a
lot more solemn putting it that way I
hadn't even thought of that
that's impressive yeah it's nothing
really
yours was impressive too so no if
anything I could probably learn a thing
or two from you and your thumbs do you
think so yeah of course you got real
teaching thumbs ah you know I was really
nervous about doing all this but in the
end I enjoyed it I'm gonna keep doing my
best for you ah me too okay right I
guess that's everyone I glanced around
the room
was a little more stressful than I
anticipated it's as if everyone is
judging me for my mediocre writing
abilities even if they're just being
nice there's no way my poems can stand
up to theirs
this is a literature club after all I
sigh I guess that's what I ended up
getting myself into across the room say
Ori and Monica are happily chatting my
eyes land on Yuri at Natsuki they
gingerly exchanged sheets of paper
sharing their respective poems as if
they as they read in tandem I each
watched their expressions change not
Sookie's eyebrows furrow and frustration
meanwhile Yuri smiles sadly what's with
this language yeah did you say something
oh it's our thing Natsuki dismissively
returns the poem to the desk with one
hand I guess you could say it's fancy
not thanks yours is cute cute you
completely missed the symbolism or
something it's clearly about feeling of
giving up how can that be cute hi I know
that I just meant the language I guess I
was trying to say something nice yeah
you mean you have to try hard to come up
with something to say nice to say Thanks
who really didn't come out nice at all
oh well I do have a couple of
suggestions if I was looking for
suggestions I would've asked someone who
actually liked it which people did by
the way say or liked it morp liked it
more liked it a lot so based on that
I'll gladly give you some jazz lessons
on my own
first of all excuse me I appreciate the
offer but I've spent a long time
establishing my writing style I don't
expect it to change anytime soon unless
of course I come across something
particularly inspiring which yours was
not which I haven't yet and more plike
my poem too you know he even told me he
was impressed by it
Natsuki suddenly stands up I didn't
realize you were so invested in trying
to impress our new member Yuri
[Music]
that's not what I you you're just your
your stands up maybe you're just jealous
that more appreciates my advice more
than he appreciated yours
do you know it didn't appreciate my
advice me that full of yourself no if I
was full of myself I would deliberately
go out of my way and make everything I
do overly cutesy Oh is everyone okay
here well you know what I wasn't the
only one whose boobs magically grew size
bigger
as soon as morp started showing up a
what Natsuki um okay that's a little
this doesn't involve you I like fighting
guys suddenly both girls tortures me and
turned towards me as if they just
noticed I was standing here my boobs
have made the same size oh yeah I guess
saving conflict here she she's just
trying to make me look bad that's not
true she started it if she could get
over herself and learn to appreciate
that simple writing is more effective
and this wouldn't have happened in the
first place what's the point in making
your poems all convoluted for no reason
the meaning should jump out did the
reader not force them to have to figure
it out help me explain that to her more
wait there's a reason we have so many
deep and expressive words in our
language it's the only way to convey
complex feelings of meaning the most
effectively avoiding them is not only
not necessarily limiting yourself it's
also a ways you understand that right
more oh how did I get dragged into this
in the first place
sound like I know anything about writing
Who am ever I agree with they'll
probably think more highly of me ah oh
boy okay conflict hey God all right I
gotta think about this one but I'm
a-thinkin plants the way I'm not wearing
pants
[Music]
all right okay all right well okay well
URIs full of herself URIs full of
herself she'd been a little uppity she's
being a little up Betty
Natsuki was defensive off the bat but
URI was dismissive off the bat that's
the two juxtapositions here like neither
of em are right I mean they're right in
their own ways but obviously I can't
take a side on it maybe Saori can L be
sorry
oh please Oh help I really don't care
what their paintings of me are Natsuki
that's he glares at me drying up any
words I had in my mouth so instead I
turn to Yuri Yuri Oh
Oh but Yuri's expression is so
defenseless that I can't bring myself to
say it anything to her yeah everyone's
fighting is making Saori uncomfortable
how can the two of you keep fighting
when you know you're making your friend
feel like this more well that's her
problem though it says in about her I
agree it's unfair for others to
interject their own feelings into our
conflict yeah and let's say or he wants
to tell you worried that what a stuck-up
jerk she's being she would never
it's your immaturity that made her upset
in the first place excuse me are you
listening to yourself this is exactly
why exactly why nobody likes stop
Natsuki Yuri you guys are my friends I
just want everyone to get along and be
happy my friends are wonderful people
and I love them because of their
differences not Suki's poems they're
amazing because they give you so many
feelings with just a few words and
Yuri's poems are amazing because they
paint beautiful pictures in your head
everyone's so talented so why are we
fighting
yeah because morp so hot well also not
Sookie's cute and there's nothing wrong
with that and Yuri's boobs are the same
as they always were begging me begging
beautiful oh say your e-series stands
triumphantly Monica stands behind her
with a bewildered expression oh I'll
make some tea
Yuri rushes off Natsuki sits down with a
blank expression on her face staring at
nothing so this is why saiary is vice
president I whisper to Monica she nods
in return to be honest I might come off
as a good leader and can organize things
but I'm not very good with people I
couldn't even bring myself to interject
as president that's kind of embarrassing
of me nah it's not like I can blame you
I wasn't able to say anything either
well I guess that just means Sayuri is
amazing in her own ways isn't it isn't
she you could say that she might be an
airhead but sometimes it's weirdly
suspicious that she knows exactly what
she's doing
I see take good care of her okay I would
hate to see her getting herself hurt
that makes two of us you can count on me
Monica smiles sweetly at me causing my
stomach to nod off well such a genuine
person really does make a good president
regardless of what she says only I could
get the chance to talk to her a little
more Oh Monica okay just about time for
us to leave how did you all feel about
sharing your poems it was a lot of fun
well I'd say it was worth it who's
alright well mostly more how about you
yeah I'd say the same it was a neat
thing to talk about with everyone
awesome in that case we'll do the same
thing tomorrow and maybe you learn
something from your friends too so your
palms will turn out even better ah I
think to myself I did learn a little
more about what kind of poems everyone
likes with any luck that means I can do
at least do a better job impressing
those I want to impress I nod to myself
with newfound determination ready to
walk home
let's go why do I have a funny feeling
that this is gonna take a horrifying
turn say Ori beams at me it truly has
been a while since the Ori and I have
spent this much time together I can't
really say I'm not enjoying it either
oh say Yuri about what happened earlier
now what do you mean you know between
urine and Sookie does that kind of thing
happen often no no no no that's really
the first time I've seen them fight like
that it's all your fault it's your fault
morp it's your fault I promise they're
both wonderful people you don't you
don't hate them do you no I don't hate
them I might be in love with them I just
wanted your opinion that's all I can see
why they make good friends with you hmm
you know more it's nice that I get to
spend time with you in the club in your
club but I think seeing you get along
with everyone is what makes me the
happiest and I think everyone really
likes you too
that's yeah every day is gonna be so
much fun
it looks like saiary still hasn't caught
on to the kind of situation I'm in sure
being friends with everyone is nice but
does it really need to stop there we'll
just have to see what the future holds
say ori ipad say re on the shoulder whop
whop i said that more to myself than to
her but it's easy to use say ori as an
internal monologue sometimes ok yeah
let's do this
righty-ho something's not right here
somes now right poof gotta go poop hoof
analysis in not lazy
special vitality essence Bonnie
unrestrained pure tenacious incongruent
[Music]
adventure socks I got special markiplier
socks they're pretty cool they got cheek
on NATO Pareto ignore the chica hair on
there that's gross
whistle Oh skipping right disowned
Sunday OOP got it okay alright I don't
know where this is going another day
passes it's time for the club meeting
already I've gotten a little more
comfortable here over the past couple
days entering the club room the useless
scene greets me hi more yo se yari
looks like you're in a good mood today
huh yeah I'm just still not used to be
you being the club [ __ ] I see that's
a pretty simple thing to you get you in
a good mood but I guess it's always the
simplest things with you anyway who your
brain real simple say Ori speaking of
which I'm kind of hungry
will you come with me to buy a snack no
thanks oh that's not like you at all I
have my reasons why don't we take a look
at your purse a Horry huh why why that
all of a sudden no reason really and she
wanted to look at it yeah ciarán ervices
nervously retrieves her coin purse she
fumbles with the latch and gets it open
then she turns it upside down and lets
contents spill in the desk only two
small coins fall out I knew it I can see
right through you sorry that's not fair
how did you even know it's simple if you
add enough money in the first place you
would have bought the snack before
coming to the club room so either you're
not hungry Windham an excuse to take a
walk where you plan to conveniently
forget that you spend all your money so
that I would
you some but there's one more thing
you're always hungry and so that only
leaves one option oh I give up
don't make me feel guilty if you feel
guilty that means you deserve to feel
guilty ha ha ha ha
Yuri suddenly giggles yeah I didn't
notice that she was listening in her
face in the book is always ah I wasn't
listening or anything it was just
something in my book was hilarious Yuri
Oh more please let me borrow some money
that's don't let don't get me involved
in that say Rory besides you should only
buy what you can responsibly afford and
frankly after pulling a mischievous
little stunt like that your suffering is
fair enough retribution whoa aah did I
just I didn't mean all that I got too
absorbed in my book mmm I really like it
when you speak your mind Yuri it doesn't
happen much but it's a fun side of you
that's there's no way you could think
that you were right though I did
something bad now I have to accept the
revolution retribution that that word
still coming from you Sayuri I guess
there's little devil inside all of us
isn't there don't let her fool you Sara
knows exactly what she's doing
and after all she told you guys she was
bringing me to the club before she even
told me you wouldn't have come if it
weren't for the cupcakes so I had to
trick netsuke into making them come on
give me more credit than that Sayuri
clap what they'll keep up out of nowhere
something smack Cirie in the face and
then tumbles onto the desk ow
what was that yeah a cookie oh okay it's
a giant cookie wrapped in plastic Cirie
glances around he's it's a miracle it's
because I paid my restitution
retribution actually that one almost
worked
ha ha ha I was just gonna give it to you
then I heard you blab about the cupcakes
it was totally worth seeing your
reaction though ha ha ha Natsuki that's
so nice of you I'm so happy
Sara hugs the cookie jeez just eat it
okay
say hurry rapidly tears open the wrapper
and takes a big bite shawl guard Sara
suddenly clasp her hand over her mouth I
bit my tongue hey you're going through a
lot over just one cookie now Sookie
takes a bite of her own cookie uh yours
looks really good to Natsuki can I try
it
geez beggars can't be choosers but yours
is chocolate yeah why do you think I
gave you that one fine
still I'm really happy that you shared
this one with me Sara gets out of
receipt and goes mine and Sookie then
wraps her arm around her oh geez oh gosh
I get it I get it
cookie still in an that Sookie reaches
up to nudge savory off of her arm
Sara suddenly leans down takes a bite of
net Sookie's cookie mouthful Cirie chops
away to safety Yuri and I laugh as well
jeez you're such a kid sometimes Monica
can you tell say Yuri yeah
now Sookie glances around Monica isn't
in the clubroom Oh where's Monica anyway
good question
have any of you heard anything about her
being late today not me either
mmm that's a bit unusual hope she's okay
great she's okay sir probably just had
something to do today she's pretty
popular after all yeah you don't think
she Jessa oh I wouldn't be surprised
she's probably more desirable than all
of us combined how that's true excuse me
Oh suddenly the door swings open sorry
I'm super sorry ah there you are I
didn't mean to be late I'm gonna save
real quick this is some dumb [ __ ] so I'm
done same right about this I hope you
guys weren't worried or anything yeah
Monica chose the club over her boyfriend
after all he's so strong-willed
boyfriend what on earth are you talking
about Monica quizzically glances at me
oh never mind man what helped you up
anyway ah well my last period was study
hall to be honest I kind of just lost
track of time that makes no sense though
you would have heard the bell ring at
least I must not have heard it since I
was practicing piano piano I wasn't
aware that you played music as well
Monica oh I don't really I just dabble
in a few Beethoven's and some some
Motz shirts anyway I just kind of
started recently I've always wanted to
learn piano that's so cool
you should play something first Monica
that's Monica looks at me maybe once I
get a little bit better I will yeah that
sounds so cool I'd also look forward to
it is that so sorry I won't let you down
more wha
Monica smiles ah I didn't mean any
pressure on you or anything like that
haha don't worry I've been practicing a
whole lot recently and I really love the
chance to share once I'm ready
I see in that case best of luck Thanks
so I didn't miss anything did I no not
really I just leave say oh he's
mischievous escapade
I'm sure Natsuki will end up complaining
to her anyway it looks like everyone has
already settled down Sara somehow
already finished off her entire cookie
Yuri's back to her book and the Sookie
disappeared into the closet oh oh I
heard netsuke utter and exasperated sigh
from within the closet she seems to be
annoyed by something and I approached
her in case she needs a hand
hmm you looking for something in there
freaking Monica she never puts my stuff
back in the right spot what's the point
of keeping her in her collected organs
did someone else is just gonna mess it
up I think he slides a bunch of stacked
books and boxes across the shelf manga
you read manga right ah sometimes manga
is one of those things where you can't
admit you're really into it until you
figure out where the other person stands
how did you know anyway I heard you
bring it up at some point
besides it's kind of written on your
face what's that supposed to mean I see
there's a lone volume of manga midst a
stack of various books on the other side
of the shelves curious I pull it out of
the stack
there it is Natsuki snatches it out of
my hand she then turns to a box of manga
and slips the volume right into the
middle of the rest ah much better
seeing a box set with one book missing
is probably the most irritating set in
the world I know that fail
I felt that feel many times I get a
closer look at the box yet she was
admiring parfait girls it's a series
I've never heard of in my life that
probably means it's either way out of my
demographic or it's simply terrible if
you're gonna judge you can do it through
the glass on the door she points to the
classroom door hey I wasn't judging
anything I didn't even say anything it
was the tone of your voice but I'll tell
you one thing more consider this a
lesson straight from the literature Club
don't judge a book by it's cover
in fact that's if he pulls out the first
volume of parfait girls on the box I'm
gonna show you exactly why she shoves
the book right into my hands ah I stared
the cover it features four girls in
colourful tyre striking animated
feminine imposes its exceedingly mo
don't just stand there
Natsuki grabs my arm and pulls me out of
the closet she then takes a seat against
the wall beneath the windowsills she
Pat's on the ground next to her
signaling me to sit there okay
wooden chairs be more comfortable I take
my seat chairs wouldn't work we can't
read at the same time like that why is
that I tried it out with Yuri with our
thumbs almost touching I guess it's
easier to be close together like this oh
don't say that you'll make me feel weird
about it
you'll make me feel weird Natsuki
crosses her arm and scooches an inch
away from me sorry I didn't exactly
expect to be sitting this close to her
either not that I can say it's
particularly bad thing I opened the book
it's only a few seconds before Natsuki
once again inches closer reclaiming the
additional space while she hopes I
didn't notice I can feel her peering
over my shoulder were much more eager to
begin reading than I am
well how long is it bends to read the
beginning hmm you don't go back and flip
through the older volumes every now and
then not really maybe sometimes after
I've already finished the series hey you
pay attention oh I am but nothing's
really happened yet so I can talk at the
same time looks like it's a bunch of
friends in high school
typical slice-of-life affair I kind of
grew out of these since it's rare for
the writing to be entertaining enough to
make throw up for the lack of plot so
what should I expect from this is there
gonna be plot cause you're gonna be lots
of plot well obviously you think I would
enjoy something that didn't have a plot
I mean well I guess I know what you're
saying
a lot of the beginning is about simple
things like there's a really funny
chapter the way there is obsessed with a
guy of the ice cream shop
but then that just helps you get to know
the characters and besides it's still
entertaining and later on there's all
kinds of drama like when they get into
all their backstories when some of the
romance starts to happen that's really
what makes it so good there are so many
touching parts and is that so it sounds
like you really know what you're talking
about
maybe I underestimated you hey wait
what's that supposed to mean oh that's
it he gives me a little shove morp just
meant that more peasant seeing you at
your full power good save
this chapters seems like it's about
baking it's just a guess but is there a
lot of baking in this manga well not see
if he paused for a moment as if she
doesn't want to admit something yeah
well it is called parfait girls so one
would surmise that baking was a
predominant feature in the thing yeah
what does that matter
it doesn't just since you enjoy baking -
right
[Music]
I just happened to get into baking
around the same time I got this manga
like I would ever get into anything
because it's in the manga I feel bad for
anybody that impressionable oh
definitely not a coincidence I guess
that explains not Sookie's interest in
baking still all the hobbies to pick up
from a manga that's definitely one of
the better ones not to mention she's
really good at it so who am I to judge
oh how adorable that's cutesy darts a
cutesy wutesy we read on for a few more
minutes I finished a couple chapters at
this point
are you sure this isn't boring for you
it's not I swear even though you're just
watching me read well I'm fine with that
if you say so I guess it's fun sharing
something with someone you like Oh
something you like with someone else
sorry
slip at the tongue a little Freudian
Floop I think that's what they call it
I'm always excited to get excited when I
convince any of my friends to pick up a
series I enjoy you know what I mean all
right mine you don't oh I don't have any
friends that's not well I wouldn't
really know what do you mean don't you
share your manga with your friends did
you not rebel dude oh you really don't
have friends oh I said geez oh I'm sorry
like I could ever get my friends to read
this they just think manga is for kids I
can't even bring it up with them without
them being all like you sell haven't
grown out of that yet makes me want to
punch them in the face oh I know those
kinds of people honestly it takes a lot
of effort to find friends who don't
judge
Mulla much less friends who are also
into it I'm already kind of a loser so I
guess I gravitated towards the other
losers over time loser loser loser
losers right you get it but it's
probably harder for someone like you huh
yeah
that's pretty accurate someone who's an
even bigger loser than I am you know
what I mean wait which part I mean I
feel like I can't even keep it up in my
own room I don't even know what my dad
would do if he found this at least it's
safe here in the club room except Monica
was kind of a jerk about it oh I just
can't win can I well it paid off in the
end didn't it I mean Here I am reading
it your lifelong dream more coming and
reading your manga your dream got
through you're welcome well it's not
like that solves any of my problems
maybe but more pretty sure it does at
least you're enjoying yourself right
[Music]
geez that's enough are you gonna keep
reading or what yeah yeah I flipped the
page suddenly and Sookie starts laughing
ha ha ha I totally forgot that happens
let's see if he puts a finger on one of
the panels
Minori is my favorite character you
always feel a little bad for her since
she's so unlucky
but it gets especially bad when oh I
shouldn't be talking about that yet just
finish this chapter
okay now Sookie's voice sparkles with
excitement it's a stark contrast to her
usual bossy tone but if she's not used
to sharing her favorite manga with her
friends I can understand why it's hard
to express in words the feeling you get
when connecting with someone like that
and being able to provide that to
Natsuki for whom it's a rare experience
the thought makes me smile little to
myself okay everyone shut your traps
dingdong Bing bong time to read your
poems here Monica does decree that it's
time to do the reading of the burbs
thusly that is now you already get tea
ready ready positions I guess oh come on
did your time be any worse sorry excuse
my but in your face I just had to strike
a pose I just need to make sure we have
enough time though you do look pretty
cozy over there yeah now Sookie suddenly
notices how close she's gotten to me she
hastily slides herself a good 12 inches
away from me all right guess I'll stop
here for now I closed the book and
handed towards netsuke you're just
giving it back when you want to know
what happens oh yeah but uh I've grown
adult I don't want to know Monica just
said it don't be dumb just take it home
with you yeah is that really all right I
say that mostly because I didn't really
plan on using my spare time to read this
well of course I would take forever to
finish if you didn't take home just
finished that one before tomorrow so we
can start the next one and if it gets
bent I will kill you by tomorrow oh I
only got part way through the volume so
far I might fall behind on some shows if
I try to get through this I suppose
that's a necessary sacrifice to seeing
no Sookie's enthusiastic face
and do you like that face or am i more
scared of what will happen if I don't
finish it all right then I stand up I
return to where I put my stuff and
carefully slip the book into my bag
okay that's to normal I don't know why
but something something's off
something's off I can tell I have an
intuition about these things but I'm all
out of time for this episode so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you think down the comments
below write another poem down there if
you would and I will read them I haven't
had a chance to yet because I've been
recording a lot but I will read those
poems so thank you everybody again and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]